you must have a thousand questions wires
really something inside me is wait
I need help
we are the spark that light the fire
with brains are still her down I was
raised to fight
for the first time and something to
fight for
you've seen this place and it drains
[Music]
Oh
something and so it lays awake
darkness
not going to go the way you think Carlos
found you I want
[Music]
destiny bb-8 punches on December 15
starwars the last Jedi got animatronics
puppetry physical effects
yeah looks fantastic this is a little
evolution of the crystal fox
[Music]
we'll do a combination of a hand puppet
they'll be animatronics in the face
and then we will make a perfect version
for CG I will then scan it to be able to
bring her to life in any way that Ryan
wants
[Music]
everybody we got a whole bunch of new
Star Wars to break down and they've done
interviews with the cast members talking
about their characters so we found out
what kylo Ren thinks of Rey what kylo
Ren thinks of himself which is something
I don't think we've got before and what
ray thinks of herself and there's really
cool and nostalgia bomb of Mark Hamill
talking about what it was like actually
physically being back on the Millennium
Falcon set because when he came on set
for the last Jedi it was literally the
first time that he'd been back on that
set since they shot Return of the Jedi
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch more Star Wars happening in the
next couple of weeks
and I'm also giving away IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
that to just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I always announce
winners at the end of videos and I'll
start with the funny stuff first the
kylo Ren raised up so Adam driver
actually had this really funny quote
where he's like he hates her talking
about Rey this girl this garbage picker
this amateur who somehow drew his
family's lightsaber to her hand
overpowering him in her bond with the
force so that sounds a little bit like
what you would expect from kylo Ren like
he's cares so much about his
relationship with Darth Vader he's
obsessed with his grandfather and she
just took the lightsaber so he's like
what the hell but then he goes on this
is actually where it gets more
interesting and yet he can't help but
Harbor an admiration for Rey
during the last Jedi so that's where you
start to see him turn in the trailer
where it almost looks like he's
extending his hand to her and where
things might go in a different direction
during episode 9 so the really cool
follow-up to that that Rian Johnson the
director talked about because everyone's
like is kylo Ren going to turn good like
what's the twist in the movie he says
there's a big part of the story that's
yet to be written
not by me talking about episode 9
because he's not writing that movie but
I don't think it's very interesting if
the whole story is just will kylo Ren
get his comeuppance he's a more
complicated character than that and I
think he deserves a more complicated
story than that
I don't see the point of trying to get
behind his mask and learn more about him
if all we're going to learn is yeah he's
just an evil guy that needs to be killed
so that just raises
bunch of red flags about his story arc I
don't think he's gonna be quite so
simple that he just has some turned and
he automatically becomes good but also
on the same coin I think that Rey will
also wind up being that complicated too
like it's not like she's going to pick
up Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber train
to become a Jedi and then automatically
be this force for good in those trailer
scenes you see her talking about
wrestling with dark and light inside of
her is the same thing happening within
kylo Ren he's just been doing it longer
than she has
then Adam driver went on to talk more
about kylo ren's backstory he says he's
been aware of his ability in himself
from such a young age that I don't think
there's a lot of people around him who
are on the same level and when he says
that he's talking about when he was at
the Jedi Academy when he was very very
young there just weren't a lot of people
on his level even at that age he says I
think there's something familiar there
as well as something to be feared or
something that he can't quite place you
get a little more context for his
relationship with his parents in their
fight during the rebellion in the
resistance he says I think the idea of
someone whose parents are very much
devoted to the cause that's something
that a lot of people could relate to
whether it be religion politics or
business not identifying with that cause
yourself I think that can give someone a
complex looking around and not seeing
yourself and not identifying with what's
around you I think that affects the way
we behave so that gives you an idea for
what kylo Ren was like with his family
growing up and how it was so easy for
Snoke to turn him just because he didn't
identify with his passionate cause that
his parents were so into which is
actually a pretty common story to
children born of political families or
people who were born into really strict
religions when he's talking about
religion though I don't think he's
talking about the religion of the force
because if you take it that way then
they are a religious family because of
the Skywalker line but you can kind of
see the way they talk about kylo Ren in
all the Rey Luke Skywalker scenes in the
trailer where he's like I sense this
greatness in him I thought he was the
new chosen one he wasn't careful to be
afraid of the power within kylo Ren and
it went sideways when kylo Ren just did
not attach himself to the values that
they were trying to teach him the cool
thing about Ray two is that she's also
somebody who doesn't necessarily
by with the resistance I think she wants
to do good but most of the resistance
storyline has been coming through binh
po in roses character obviously we
haven't seen a whole lot of rose and the
trailers but we've seen a lot of behind
the scenes since she's mostly with finn
for this movie but daisy ridley says she
doesn't really know what she wants she's
really trying to do the right thing in
morally her compass is pointing north
but the resistance is really not that
much to her I mean she's been left her
whole life and very quickly is eager to
sort of help other people which is
wonderful she wants to be a part of
something I mean everyone wants to be a
part of something so the interesting
thing about that is it is she's just
willing to do something she wants to do
good but she's not exactly sure what
that is because she's wrestling with
darkness and light inside of her and
she's not completely attached to the
resistance so when we talk about
characters having more complicated
stories I think they just want to leave
the door open for Snoke to appeal to
some of those things inside of her try
to give her a purpose in the way that
Luke Skywalker doesn't immediately jump
on that bandwagon so moving into luke
skywalker territory so obviously like
very emotional scene of him walking onto
limonium falcon probably the best moment
in the latest trailers that they've
started dropping just seeing all the
lights power on in him just being almost
a little confused and nostalgic just
trying to remember himself because it's
been so long but he says when he was
actually on the set before he'd uh you
know put his costume on him before they
started shooting scenes he was gonna go
walk on to the Millennium Falcon set in
the Lucasfilm people asked him if they
could send a documentary crew with him
so that they could film the first time
Mark Hamill himself had been back on the
Palladium Falcon and of course he was
like yeah sure you know tell them they
can follow me on in the way he described
it is is it was sort of like visiting an
old house that you lived in when you
were a kid I mean I just welled up with
emotion and I said I need to be by
myself he goes on to say they had
recreated it down to every last detail
that I remember the oil drips the
hanging pipes just everything the dice
in the cockpit one of his best quotes is
he said I figured when the prequels came
out plus a few years people would just
forget about us but it never really went
away
you get this real sense that he's
wrestling with the idea of being a pop
culture God and like what that means to
him and how he tries to give that back
to the fans he's on the press tour right
now they started in Mexico City if you
can believe it there are people in the
world they don't know that there's a
Star Wars movie coming out but everybody
let me know what you think of this and I
almost forgot the really cool news you
guys will probably be excited about this
this is going to be the longest Star
Wars movie of all time it'll be two and
a half hours but what'll happen is is
I'll just do new Star Wars as we get new
stuff but just leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below
there'll be a whole bunch of Star Wars
coming in the next couple weeks
congratulations to Vega thawne you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round the next
time I post new Star Wars but you can
click here for that other trailer and
you can click here for all my Justice
League Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight